salut l'adolescence est sans aucun doute
le meilleur moment pour tenter
l'impossible genre un petit saut comme
ça de 20 centimètres en plus les ados à
notre époque actuelle c'est plutôt les
jeunes de 10 à 24 ans la plage est
longue ça laisse quand même pas mal de
temps avant d'entrer dans l'âge adulte
certains des ados qu'on va découvrir
dans cette vidéo ont l'ambition de
nettoyer les océans 2 2 les
milliardaires à 18 ans pendant que
d'autres construisent leur propre maison
à 13 ans moi je faisais quoi cet âge là
bref on sait bien on est rempli
d'énergie à l'adolescence et puis
doucement et nous quitte sans nous
prévenir un même pas un petit coup de
filet puis on rate le réveil colmatant
non il faudrait une solution à tout ce à
quoi une solution rapide efficace fiable
genre le partenaire de cette vidéo par
exemple mais marc nohr cadets
laboratoire biogaran sponsorise cette
vidéo et propose une gamme de cinq
produits sous forme de compléments
alimentaires autour du bien-être mental
plus que jamais au coeur de nos vies en
ce moment plus n'aurez qu'à vous propose
de renforcer votre mémoire votre
stabilité émotionnelle votre sommeil
votre performance intellectuelle et de
limiter votre stress au quotidien
comment et que tu ais je veux dire
évidemment j'ai étudié la composition de
chaque produit on a pris du temps pour
ça ils sont composés de complexe ça
phénol à base de deux ingrédients
profiter puis d'une association des
extraits de plantes de vitamines et de
minéraux il faudrait une vidéo entière
pour vous expliquer le fonctionnement
complet mais si vous êtes intéressés par
leurs produits si vous voulez en savoir
plus ce qu'ils voulaient détaillé tout
ça vous allez sur le site qui à paris
simon complément bien être le lien est
dans la description où tout est très
très bien détaillé transparent et simple
à comprendre qui n'est pas toujours le
cas qu'on parle de compléments
alimentaires merci encore au laboratoire
biogaran une rocade avoir sponsorisé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à visiter leur
site le lien est dans la description
pourra savoir plus et trouver le ou les
produits qui correspondront à vos
besoins onze ans à cette vidéo si elle
vous donne pas des idées pour occuper
vos soirées votre week end je m'appelle
plus fabien olicard déjà que c'est pas
toujours le cas
[Musique]
certaines personnes ville des choses que
peu d'entre nous auront l'occasion de
faire un jour il ya un américain qui
s'appelle boivent que qu'hier il a fait
clairement partie de ces gens là pendant
ses vacances d'été 2010 9 ans et n ya
pas très longtemps il avait 17 ans wolf
était en stage à la nasa au centre
goddard c'est dans le marigot à la nasa
déjà l'histoire elle pourrait s'arrêter
là qui fait son petit stage d'été à la
nasa tu vois je le fais chez flunch
bombay lui il avait de la chance il
regarder les étoiles et son maître de
stage qui s'appelle vis line cost of a
décidé de lui donner un petit travail
sympa un travail d'étude qui va marquer
c'est analyser les données de test alors
tess s'était pas sa petite collègues
étaient en stage aussi tess c'est un
projet ça s'écrit t es s c'est un tout
petit satellite qui apporte job
principal de recenser les exoplanètes
qui sont proches de la terre une
exoplanète c'est quoi c'est une planète
où potentiellement l'être humain
pourrait habiter bon ça c'est ce qu'on
espérait mais en tout cas qui
potentiellement pourrait abriter la vie
wolf ai dit ok j'accepte le job et
comprend très vite comment ça fonctionne
trois jours seulement après le début de
son stage au wolf explique avoir vu un
signal qui venait d'un système appelé
toi
1338 si on dirait le début d'une comédie
musicale bienvenue à toi 1338 whaou
tours
il a cru débarque c'était une éclipse
stellaire mais comme le timing était pas
vraiment bon ça collait pas il a creusé
un peu il a compris que c'était une
planète et ses deux soleils malin le
wolof du coup il signe un article avec
des astronomes de la nasa grâce à cette
découverte je veux dire en termes de
rapports de stage tu dis ben moi j'ai
publié un papier avec des astronomes bon
en lien avec la nasa que je dis plus
découvert une planète et cdh allait
vraiment ça ça me calme mais peut-être
ces courants les gens qui font des
stages de dengue a dit si vous avez fait
des dingueries en stage comme ça dans
dans les commentaires je suis sûr qu'il
y en a qui vont nous bluffer moi j'ai
fait des stages très basique
pendant que des ados découvrent deux
planètes il y en a qui préfèrent rester
les pieds sur terre et qui construisent
leur maison bientôt avoir 40 ans en deux
ans que c'est moi le temps mais j'ai pas
construit de maisons encore et bien lui
peut-il qui est un américain également
de 13 ans s'est construit une taille ni
house donc c'est les micros maison vous
savez on en voit de plus en plus qu'ils
sont sûrs remarque et ça lui a pas coûté
non plus une fortune ça lui coûtait 1500
$ en convertissant ça fait environ 1300
euros il a utilisé 75% de matériel
recyclé et comment lui est venue cette
idée et b en regardant des vidéos sur
youtube qui montre l existence détail
n'gaous il est tombé amoureux de ce
concept et il a décidé de construire la
sienne je trouve ça vraiment champ mais
il a commencé par faire des plans
ensuite avec les petites économies et
tout ça et l'aide de sa famille
évidemment il a commencé à réunir les
matériaux pour la construire et pour
récolter les derniers dollars qui lui
manquait il l'a lire chez les voisins
tondre la pelouse le mec s'est construit
sa maison lui même anton brand épouse
alors évidemment son père l'a aidé sur
la construction de la maison en
elle-même et sa mère lui a donné un coup
de main sur l'aménagement à l'intérieur
je ne peux apprendre des autres au final
ça thani a fait trois mètres de long
elle fait un mètre cinquante de large et
elle contient une cuisine avec frigo un
salon avec une télé une chambre avec une
fenêtre de tout quoi il a tout bon après
je me demande s'il est quand même pas
raccordés chez ses parents pour
l'électricité louis le concept des tiny
ça vient des états unis à la fin des
années 20 ces dernières années il ya
plein d'entreprises françaises qui sont
lancés dans le secteur de la conception
il y en a qui sont vraiment magnifiques
de nous
énormément envie moi je vous le dis j'ai
un tout petit terrain je rêve d'avoir
une taille mais aussi vous en fabriquer
vous même comme lui vous me contacter
pareil pour laisser un com vous me dites
on se retrouve mais je sais pas une
blague ça paraît une blague mais ce pas
une blague je cherche magnifique tacle
[Musique]
alors là on va pas se mentir il y en a
ils se lèvent de bonne heure il
retrousse les manches et issue tout ce
qu'ils peuvent pour avoir ce qu'ils ont
qui en a ils font ça comme ça et cette
voix là exactement ça tombe du ciel je
vais vous parler de david kevin
l'ennemane c'est un adolescent allemand
18 ans il a hérité de son père gagne
carl hayman d'une part qui représente
50% de la chaîne de drogueries a demandé
m c'est droguerie marque alors ça veut
dire quoi en dollars ça veut dire
environ 3,3 milliards de dollars la 18
ans est à plus de deux milliards d'euros
environ sur ton compte en banque dmc une
chaîne de drogueries plutôt bien
implanté parce que ça s'agit du leader
européen sur ce marché izon 3700
magasins avec des employés en veux tu en
voilà et alors le plus marrant on dit
oui c'est son père aussi l'atout
construit tout cela non pas du tout il
était pas du tout actif dans la boîte il
avait juste donné les fonds nécessaires
au lancement de la chaîne en 74 et après
il a juste eu récolter les fruits de sa
réussite il a juste prêté un peu tu ne
dépare quoi enfin même pas prêté il a
investi dedans donc son fils kevin est
devenu du jour au lendemain le 925e
homme le plus riche de la planète et
surtout le plus jeune d'entre eux
attention on parle quand même d'un
héritage terre que les milliards ne
rachète pas un père vivant un sas et ça
reste dramatique l'héritage est temps
qu'on a parlé des milliardaires j'avais
fait une vidéo le dessus je pas si vous
l'avez vu en tout cas la fortune des
milliardaires est passé de 8 dollars
2020 à 13,1 millions de dollars en 2021
mais on parle pas de la fortune mondiale
on parle juste de l'argent de ce conte
plein d'argent et bien c'est marrant
parce que plus en d'argent bout ils ont
d'argent se dire que par exemple quand
ils ont envie de se faire un resto il
achète en reste mais là pour kevin
niveau revenu on est quand même
largement devant mozilla bridge ce qu'on
verra tout à l'heure qui a créé son
entreprise à l'âge de neuf ans et qui se
débrouille vraiment pas mal vous allez
voir
celui qui a cassé le game aussi ses boys
hans l'at il a décidé à l'âge de 16 ans
de nettoyer les océans voilà il s'est
dit attends c'est quoi ce bordel
concrètement il s'est lancé dans son
projet à ses 18 ans donc deux ans plus
tard et il son projet s'appelle the
oceans clean up c'est une organisation à
but non lucratif dans l'idée de déployer
un filet de 600 m de long en forme de u
u sur 3 mètres de profondeur pour choper
un maximum de déchets sur son passage sa
pelouse comme ça une fois que les
conteneurs sont pleins les déchets sont
envoyés au recyclage et s'entraîner et
ils ont une deuxième vie et en 2021
beaubois ian et son équipe se sont
attaqués au vortex de déchets de l'océan
pacifique nord c'est un délire mais pas
dans le bon sens en gros c'est une
quantité astronomique d'ordures qui se
situe entre hawaï et la californie
pourquoi ces dix parce que sous l'effet
de la rotation de la terre les courants
marins créer ce qu'on appelle des gir
océanique qui évolue dans le sens
horaire dans l'hémisphère nord et qui
emportent avec eux les déchets qui se
trouve sur la partie sage pour finir par
les les emprisonner n'est plus loin dans
un tourbillon et l'objectif de boya nous
voyons je commence a dit il est énorme
c'est de réduire de 90% le nombre de
plastique qu'il ya dans les océans d'ici
2040 pareil moi à son âge que j'avais
des ambitions par exemple qu'est ce
qu'on fait ce week end d'ailleurs tant
qu'on parle de ça je sais pas si vous
connaissez le ce qu'on appelle le
septième continent c'est une masse de
déchets notamment plastique qui flottent
dans l'océan pacifique et qui fait plus
de six fois la taille de la france vous
imaginez c'est un continent de déchets
six fois plus gros que la france créé
par l'homme évident selon les
estimations le septième continent
poserait 4000 tonnes si on le sortait de
l'eau au coin donc on pourrait tous
essayer de réduire un peu nos déchets
pour le bien de la paix nord
[Musique]
mozilla bridge faisant que parler un peu
de tout à l'heure ça me met préféré ça a
été le plus jeune entrepreneur du monde
ring ça il a commencé à lancer son
business de noeuds papillon en 2011 il
avait 9 ans c'est kiki d'avoir neuf ans
à la base et là vous vous dites oui
alors fabien qu'est ce qui fait qu'on a
envie de se lancer dans le monde de
l'entrepreneuriat quand on a neuf ans
pour faire des noeuds papillon à cette
époque-là mozilla est attiré par le look
des jonas brothers et de justin bieber
qui ont l'habitude de mettre souvent des
noeuds papillon quand ils sont sur
l'état pions et louise distillés
je veux aussi en avoir donc il fait
sombre son petit look de petit garçon
avec mais dans le magasin ils trouvent
que des noeuds qui sont je cite un selon
lui unis est moche et c'est là qu'il
décide alors de créer ses propres noeuds
papillons colorés à motifs et c'est sa
grand mère couturière il donne des cours
de couture elle lui achète même sa
propre machine à coudre et à va lui
donner des chutes de tissus pour qu'ils
commencent à sembler ses créations
autant vous dire que à l'école quand à 9
ans étudie wayne mais là je peux pas
venir parce que je prends des cours de
couture avec ma grand mère noire menace
les accoudoirs et c'est pas le truc
socialement le plus fou mais en fait au
final 28 gagne parce que ses potes à
l'école devienne fans de son look et
c'est à cause de leur engouement que
mozilla crée alors son entreprise on
joue donc là vous vous dites oui il a
vendu 2 3 noeuds papillon à ses copains
attendait trois ans après avoir lancé sa
société son chiffre d'affaires
atteignait déjà les 90 mille dollars
c'est pas mal il ya cette époque meusien
recevait déjà des commandes de grandes
marques de prêt-à-porter de luxe est il
engagé trois personnes pour faire les
noeuds lui même évidemment sa mère est
une vraie employé comme quoi et j'aime
bien le message pas besoin de faire des
années d'études pour lancer une grosse
activité c'est un truc dont je parle
dans mon podcast du pot quand je sais
personne c'est que je fais un petit
casse il vous en ai jamais parlé mais ce
qui le si vous n'êtes que je parle
[Musique]
il devient grand maître international
aux échecs à 12 ans et en 2002 serge et
carjac un américain de 12 ans et sept
mois là on compte les mois ça compte
devient grand maître international aux
échecs il est resté le plus jeune à
avoir obtenu ce titre jusqu'au 30 juin
2021 jour où habite mme agnew nichera
mois déjà au fait la séquence plusieurs
fois c'était un américain lui aussi qui
est devenu grand maître international
mais à l'âge de 12 ans et 4 mois c'est
pour ça que les mois ça compte quatre
mois et 25 jours même fait précis il ya
que quatre autres joueurs dans
l'histoire qui ont réussi à accéder au
club très fermé de ceux qui ont obtenu
le titre de grand maître international
avant d'atteindre leurs treize ans toi
tu étais grand maître avant tout alors
ces grands
pas vers m tu voyages à l'étranger ton
père est américain ouais donc tu étais
grand maître international
avancé abus manioc et est devenu en 2010
neuf grands maîtres à l'âge de 10 ans
évidemment battant également le record
qui avait avant lui bon après abby
manioc il s'est pris de passion pour les
échecs à l'âge de deux ans et demi c'est
aussi pour ça qu'il avait de la vence il
avait appris avec son père il a commencé
à battre son père quand il avait 5 ans à
8 ans il est devenu champion d'amérique
dans la catégorie des moins de 8 ans
lors d'un tournoi d'échecs
internationale en france nous on a quand
même 50 grands maîtres internationaux
mais celui à l'être devenu le plus jeune
et etienne bacrot il a obtenu à 14 ans
et 2 mois on se fait battre comme quoi
si vous avez un projet aller jusqu'au
bout mais attendez à une personne que ce
soit pour créer votre entreprise de
noeuds papillon pour fabriquer votre
propre micro maison pour nettoyer les
océans la valeur n'attend pas le poids
des années c'est pour ça mais c'est pas
de moi de ce que je veux dire c'est
attendait pas d'avoir fait vos 15 ans
d'études pour vous lancer dans ce que ce
dont vous avez envie à part si vous
voulez être médecin surtout chirurgien
tout ça attendez en fait la fête les
études quand même mais après partait du
principe que rien n'est vraiment
impossible avec de la volonté je mets
quand même une nuance parce que oui des
trucs qui sont plus compliquées on est
d'accord en attendant moi ici je vous
mets deux autres vidéos la vidéo
christoly car si vous n'avez pas vu ce
concept regarder ça et puis là c'est un
c'est un casse tête que j'ai fait
récemment qui s'appelle la smiley boxe
prenez soin de vous à très bientôt
bientôt les deux millions d'abonnés si
vous n'êtes pas abonné je compte sur
vous ciao